le boxeur adonis stevenson est dans un
état critique après un ko asséné par son
adversaire hier soir à québec et pour en
parler je reçois georges d'espéranche et
les neurochirurgiens et président des
experts en évaluation médico légal du
québec bonjour docteur l'espérance donc
adonis stevenson et les prisons en soins
intensifs depuis hier on a compris qu'il
a reçu plusieurs coups dont le dernier
qui l'a mis ko et qu'il a fait s'écraser
au sol
tout d'abord au plan physiologique chaos
qu'est ce que ça fait au cerveau en fait
une commotion cérébrale majeure on
pourrait dire parce que le but de la
boxe contrairement aux routes pas où la
commotion est un accident qui arrive
dans le sport mais la boxe le but c'est
de donner une commotion cérébrale
oui on peut discuter de la pertinence
d'avoir un tel sport c'est peut-être un
autre débat mon pour l'approcher au 6
mai au point de vue physiologique c'est
vraiment une commotion cérébrale c'est à
dire une perte de conscience et des
repères que le cerveau peut emmagasiner
de ce qu'on pense qu'hier et a pu il a
pu se relever de prendre une dose puis
m'a donné et je pense qu'il était
incapable de marcher mais m'avait l'air
confus donc là on s'en rend compte qu'à
des dommages au cerveau
oui en fait je ne connais pas le dossier
un évidement mais le fait qu'il était
conscient par la suite que ce soit par
la suite se soit détérioré syndic plutôt
un élément commotionnels important
majeur
plutôt qu'une lésion et tracer les bras
tel qu'une hémorragie animateur social
et cetera ils auraient pu éventuellement
avoir un hématome épidural qu'on appelle
mais dans ce cas il aurait été opéré ce
qui n'est pas le cas donc pour l'instant
ce que l'on sait et tous les patients
qui arrivent avec un accident de ce type
là c'est la même chose c'est d'abord
l'évaluation initiale du patient à
l'urgence qu'on appelle le combat
glasgow l'échelle de commandes glasgow
et par la suite l'imagerie dans son
coffre ignore dans quel état il était
lorsqu'il est arrivé
à l'hôpital mais par la suite à
l'imagerie on voit s'il ya ou non des
hémorragies cérébrales s'il ya ou non de
les dames c'est mal de l'enflure du
cerveau si vous voulez et à ce moment là
le traitement si le patient n'est pas
très bien c'est de le mettre facilement
le traitement depuis 20 ans de se le
mettre dans ce qu'on appelle un combat
barbituriques induit ou incombe
artificielle qui en d'autres termes veut
dire une anesthésie générale prolongée
où l'on contrôle tous les paramètres de
l'individu bon dans son entourage on
disait que les médecins avaient dit que
les 48 heures les prochaines 48 heures
seront cruciales j'imagine pour le
stabiliser et voir évaluer aussi comment
en fait on parle de séquelles ou c'est
peut-être non plus à l'échelle on sait
seulement que l'on peut pas le savoir à
l'avancé un des éléments les plus
indicatif des séquelles ultérieure c'est
le glasgow
michel komajda zone lorsque le patient
arrive et bien sûr aussi s'il ya des
débats des lésions anatomiques
il m'aura j cérébrale est reproché
matheuse etc si rien tout ça et qu'il
n'y a que 1 ghz mais les dames cérébrale
général le patient va s'en sortir mais
il peut quand même gardé des séquelles
il rien qui indique qu'il n'aura pas de
séquelles ou qui va en avoir
ça prend vraiment l'évolution par
ailleurs pour répondre à ce que les
familles des dents l'écart à 12 que les
médecins ont dit dans les quarante huit
ans parce que l'on peut voir comment
évolue le patient comment évolue la
pression intracrânienne comment évaluer
le patient de façon générale et dans un
tel cas on peut avoir une idée si
patients vont avoir des problèmes pour
sortir du coup moi réduit ou pas aux
documents
oui tout à fait un document de plus en
plus c'est relativement nouveau cd des
séquelles pour les boxeurs c'est un
sport comme vous disiez particulier
parce qu'on ne parle pas d'une commotion
par par hasard ou par par jeu tirant un
geste qui n'a pas été délibéré
là c'est le but de la boxe de frapper
frapper à la tête alors que dans notre
sport on interdit de frapper à la tête
où on oublie je le port du casque à rené
n'importe quel sport
la commotion c'est le rock et le ski le
football la commotion voit un accident
le but de la boxe c'est de donner une
commotion serbe
nackaerts une commotion cérébrale j'ai
déjà dit ailleurs et je le répète devant
vous un sport où le règlement est de ne
pas avoir droit de donner deux coups en
bas de la ceinture mais qu'on donne une
commotion cérébrale lorsqu'une société
rendu à protéger les bijoux de famille
plus que le cerveau on aime ce problème
on devrait réfléchir le sport de la boxe
et de donner une commotion cérébrale ça
n'a pas de sens
et là on parle de possibilité de démence
du boxeur qui au moment particulier donc
c'est un type alzheimer lancé fait le
petit pugilistique qui est décrite
depuis une bonne centaine d'années quand
même waouh ça fait très longtemps que
c'est connu parce que justement les
boxeurs reçoivent des coups très
fréquents ils peuvent aussi même s'ils
n'ont pas de séquelles immédiate plus
tard ils vont développer diverses et
quelques chroniques à long terme dans
leur cerveau et on vient on fait
maintenant un lien entre la boxe et la
maladie de lou gehrig aussi oui mais là
on est dans les eaux et dans l'hypothèse
où ims qui ce qui devient plus précis
maintenant c'est le lien entre la boxe
et les maladies dégénératives cognitives
c'est le seul le cran de grands
chapitres des maladies dégénératives et
aussi d'autres types de pathologies
comme le parking sommes par exemple
aider beaucoup de grands boxeurs
professionnels ont développé des
maladies neurodégénératives
ultérieurement puis en terminant avant
2015 à une association de médecins
australienne qui réclamaient
l'interdiction de la boxe après la mort
par ko d'un jeune acteur vous êtes
médecin votre votre mission c'est
justement de sauver des vies ou du moins
atténuer les séquelles
vous disiez tantôt donc c'est quand même
ça relance un débat sain de nombreuses
années j'étais
l'honneur des présidents d'associations
des neurochirurgiens du québec à une
époque pour un dessin aussi dans le box
ans j'avais dit on devrait faire un
moratoire au québec et au canada exigé
de la part des neurochirurgiens exigé
que la boxe soient arrêtés et on m'a
répondu que c'était une bataille perdue
il ya énormément d'argent qui est
impliquée là-dedans mais à sa base même
un spa où le but est de donner une
lésion cérébrale à l'autre ça n'a pas de
sens en soi
dr lespérance merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec lui merci au revoir